si tiene apnea obstructiva del sueño su
respiración se detiene por breves
periodos de tiempo mientras está dormido
normalmente cuando usted respira el aire
ingresa a través de su boca y nariz y
baja a su garganta también llamada
faringe el aire fluye por su tubo de
aire o tráquea esparciéndose a través de
una estructura parecida a un árbol de
tubos pequeños hacia sus pulmones
cada vez que usted respira la presión de
succión negativa jala los tejidos suaves
en su boca y faringe hacia adentro los
músculos en su faringe responden jalando
los tejidos suaves hacia afuera
nuevamente lo que mantiene abierta su
vía de aire
cuando usted duerme es normal para los
músculos de su boca lengua y faringe
relajarse ligeramente pero no lo
suficiente para bloquear la vía de aire
si tiene apnea obstructiva del sueño los
músculos de su boca y faringe pueden
relajarse demasiado
su lengua cae al tejido suave en el
techo de su boca presionando contra la
parte posterior de su garganta esto
bloquea completamente el flujo de aire
hacia sus pulmones
y la falta de oxígeno en sus pulmones lo
despierta
usted puede jadear por aire para
reestablecer el flujo de aire antes de
dormir nuevamente el ciclo de la apnea y
despertar puede pasar muchas veces en la
noche evitando un sueño relajado
los factores que pueden contribuir a la
apnea obstructiva incluyen obesidad
porque más grasa puede presentarse en
las paredes de la faringe
una quijada pequeña o que retrocede con
una vía de aire estrecha
pérdida de tono muscular en su faringe
debido al envejecimiento
y amígdalas hinchadas
síntomas comunes de la apnea obstructiva
del sueño son roncar
y dolores de cabeza matutinos
somnolencia crónica diurna
fatiga
irritabilidad
y concentración disminuida
si es dejada sin tratamiento la apnea
obstructiva del sueño puede conducir a
complicaciones como presión arterial
alta enfermedad del corazón
latidos irregulares llamados arritmia
accidente cerebrovascular y diabetes
su médico puede recomendar cambios en su
estilo de vida para tratar la apnea
obstructiva del sueño incluyendo perder
peso
dormir de costado
no fumar
y evitar sustancias que pueden ponerlo
somnoliento como el alcohol y los
sedantes
apnea obstructiva del sueño moderada o
leve un dispositivo oral puede mantener
su vía abierta este dispositivo trabaja
jalando su quijada hacia adelante y
moviendo tanto su lengua como el techo
de su boca lejos de la parte posterior
de su garganta el tratamiento más
efectivo y común para la apnea
obstructiva del sueño es una máquina de
presión positiva continua de la vía
aérea o cp ap esta máquina bombea aire a
través de un tubo hacia una máscara que
encaja en su nariz o en ambos su nariz y
su boca la presión mediana de aire de la
máquina cpp ayuda a mantener abierta la
vía de aire permitiendo que tenga un
sueño profundo y tranquilo